[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 96 i'm here
with dr heather heing i am of course dr
brett weinstein we have and we've got
madison weinstein we have a labrador
retriever here as well who i've just
bonked on the nose she doesn't seem to
care but i feel bad
oh doggie
all right uh
so we're here it is uh it is episode 96
it is september 11th we will be talking
some about that today we are going to be
talking about the final chapter of our
book which is due to be released in
three short days so uh we're going to be
talking about about that some too we are
very excited about this once again it's
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century we have one and only one copy
which we had to beg for which we had to
beg for and um some of the people we've
been talking to about it which we'll
talk to you about having talked to them
about a little bit here today um have
not received copies either so it's uh
it's apparently scarce apparently in
high demand which is why the copies are
scarce i do want to make one correction
okay you said it will be out in three
short days i expect them to feel like
three very long days to us yes well um
reality being what it is no matter how
they feel they will be the same length
that's a very modernist laboratory
focused kind of approach
um yeah i don't i don't see it as
laboratory focus so much as like reality
focus clock reality it's definitely
there's a moment at which that's the way
time starts progressing for people um
and i'm not saying it's not real as
we've talked about before but 72 hours
is 72 hours no matter how you feel about
it
we we should we should put a pin in this
discussion and return to it because it
is both what you say is true but it's
very much a laboratory clock perspective
and um
not so much a uh an ancestral one
yes but definitely not a postmodern one
which is what it felt like where you
were going so never
um so we're going to be talking um
about all those things we just said so
first um if you're watching on youtube
consider trying it out on odyssey
it seems to be getting better all the
time we know that there are uh
some issues that remaining but they are
working hard on it that's
odysse and the chat is enabled on
odyssey where we've got moderators um
ready and waiting to en engage with you
um you can for the second half of our
podcast uh write questions in when we
will be doing the q a uh that is at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com
consider joining our patreons
we have stuff available at darkhorse
darkhorsepodcaststore.darkhorsepodcast.org
podcast
i've got a uh
a newsletter at
naturalselections.substance.com
and in
uh homage to the book and uh and to this
feeling like you know a big moment for
us um i have asked that we not do any
ads today so there are no there are no
paid ads everything we are talking about
today is um
is completely from our hearts although
as we've said before we only take
sponsors for ads uh for products that we
actually uh stand behind so before we
get into the into talking about 911 and
fourth frontier which is the subject of
the final chapter of our book
uh we want to mention uh we were on we
were on joe rogan this week and as usual
he is uh he is charming and wonderful
and smart and humble and all of that
yes well i was just going to say so this
obviously took us to texas his new home
and
it was a whirlwind tour for us not only
were we in austin but we were in dallas
and we got back yesterday and
oddly flying in we had flown out of
portland where summer has been
mostly lovely except for the heat wave
that we had
um but we flew in and it was cloudy and
it looked like
winter there was snow on the ground well
not snow but trash on the ground and uh
anyway that's true
no it's all true except the snow part
which i but anyway
it is uh nice and sunny here today i'm
glad to see that that was a brief
departure from our summer weather we'll
still do a few more weeks of this yeah
well this is usually your role but as
you know winter is coming
thank you yes this is an important point
for our our listeners except those in
the southern hemisphere to know about
and to prepare for and we should at some
point talk about how one might
rationally prepare for such things
that's what we're here for to introduce
you to the concept of winter now
actually i'm not this week um but uh you
know in a week and a half on my in my
sub stack natural selections i'm going
to be talking about the fact of the
um the fall equinox
fall in the northern hemisphere vernal
spring in the southern hemisphere and a
full moon happening at basically the
same moment
in
tennis day's time
and what what both of those things have
meant to ancestral pupils and to us
today
but i just wanted to say that um
before so the joe rogan episode dropped
on thursday i think um
and
we had we had you know the book had been
doing okay for not being out and having
basically no pr except for what we're
doing for it right it had been doing
great enough that the copies were scarce
right and so we were on amazon top of
the heap in these niche categories like
human geography
and cultural anthropology and then then
we got there in evolution and then in
biology and then even science and math
um but then we slept into the top
hundred and that was pretty awesome and
then yesterday we watched it climb and
we cracked the top ten across across all
books and let's see how it's gonna
oscillate around and all
and this is thrilling this is totally
thrilling for us we love this book is
gonna be out there in the world uh we
really hope that
many many of you buy it but more to the
point that many many of you read it that
it will be you know available in
libraries for people who don't have the
capacity or interest in buying it but we
really hope that it's very widely read
but as it is climbing into the into the
top ten
where it's been now moving you know a
slot or two
uh we've discovered a nemesis
and um there's this one other book on
amazon's best seller list that we are
swapping positions with at least for
these last many hours it's a fierce
battle i think it's it's not a battle
between good and evil so much uh but i
don't know i you know i had something to
say here in the show but uh maybe you
wanted to to take us there you want me
to show well i mean i think it does feel
like a battle a personal yeah
yeah the the very hungry caterpillar is
the the book uh we we briefly surpassed
it and now so zach can you show that
since that didn't go as i was expecting
it too
okay well in any case um the very hungry
caterpillar we briefly passed it and
then
there was a
turnaround and the the very hungry
caterpillar made a comeback and it has
now
uh raced past us which i strongly
suspect the many haters that we have
picked up uh to the podcast i believe
they are buying up copies of the very
hungry caterpillar
do you yes that is my suspicion i see
okay so uh here we go um i would not
call this racing past us um we have been
we have been neck and neck uh we were
ahead of it briefly and we are behind it
now but i do i mean i again i don't
think this is a battle between good and
evil because you know we too as
apparently the entire freaking world
were fans of the very hungry caterpillar
it wasn't the best children's book out
there but it was it was good look it was
solid that is racing past us for a
caterpillar
they're not known for their speed and
but i should point to all those people
buying the caterpillar book that we
mentioned caterpillars there are
caterpillars in our books absolutely um
i'm sure they're hungry because
caterpillars tend to be hungry yeah well
and i also think the title of this book
was something of a warning to us and we
just we read it too literally
yes yes in fact maybe the very hungry
caterpillar is the metaphor we've been
looking for to be using in
in fact the fourth frontier chapter of
our own book uh which we will be talking
about it's obvious in retrospect it is
obvious in retrospect so um
i guess there is somehow
the email i sent to our wonderful 17
year old son and producer of the dark
horse podcast never reached him but i
will say we are one of zach you just
show briefly one of amazon's hot new
releases as well so that's pretty
exciting
all right um on to
more serious topics absolutely yeah all
right uh i had a couple things i wanted
to say about
9 11. um the first thing i wanted to do
was talk a little bit about
something
for those who are old enough to remember
911 as adults and it seems so recent to
me it's very hard to accept that it's 20
years ago but
in any case for those who are old enough
to remember it
as adults
there was a
shocking
pattern that emerged in the immediate
aftermath of the attacks
and as i remember it and it's a little
bit hard to document actually but as i
remember it
the fact of the attacks caused
a system
a very sophisticated system of
journalism and all that had been
captured and had become corrupt and
feeble and unable to do the most basic
jobs that journalism for example does
that system suddenly didn't know what to
do and started doing actual journalism
it seemed almost by accident so this
very slick product that was produced
that you know we were told was the news
on any given day
actually emerged as a real phenomenon
briefly in the aftermath of the attacks
and i think it was actually connected
the attacks happened and they were such
a profound shock to the system that
actually ads were taken off of
television it was understood that it was
unseemly and out of place to have ads
and so suddenly what you effectively had
was everybody drafted into a kind of um
you know public broadcasting milieu
suddenly people who were reporters doing
whatever corporate wanted them to report
they were all in the same story they had
their microphones in hand the cameras
were right there already and they did
journalism because it was the obvious
thing to do right and it was so
different from normal right you don't
realize how abnormal things are
uh under normal circumstances or how at
odds the narrative is from what's
actually taking place until an event
like this causes people
to suddenly wake up and start doing this
job and then i remember i mean this went
on for some time my recollection is a
couple weeks
um i would have said a little less than
a week i don't remember but in any case
at some point the ads returned yeah and
normalcy returned and the narrative
control the sky is filled again right
there it was it was something i would
have said a week-ish where there were no
planes in the sky and there were no ads
on the television and when you walk down
to the street it both seemed quiet
and
for many of us anyway
more more open and of course there were
many people who were immediately
targeted
so it was it was a less open time for
some people immediately
after 9 11. um but many of us found an
ability to reach across gaps that we
hadn't seen before
yes um
the
i want to point to the last chapter
which we talked about last week because
at some level the penultimate chapter
the penultimate chapter yes the
last chapter we discussed the
penultimate chapter of our book which
talks about culture and consciousness
and about the moment at which we shift
modes when we realize that something is
not accounted for in
our software and that we have to
bootstrap new routines in order to
figure out how to move forward and this
was very it's really i think the
clearest example of this in our
lifetimes that we've experienced that 9
11 was so
far outside of our normal experience
that suddenly we all
kind of woke up and we saw each other
for the first time the camaraderie that
was evident everywhere as people who
ordinarily might not have even spoken to
each other
suddenly had the very same topic on
their minds and it was impossible for
them not to interact it was a very as
terrible as the event was it was a very
healthy response for a time
and then whatever it is that happens
doesn't recognize this as a positive
change and an opportunity or it does
recognize it as an opportunity but it's
a different sort of opportunity
and
we ended up you know in the aftermath of
9 11 as polarized as as
we've been really
um
so i wanted to just call that out
because the having lived through it
and then
i can't remember the last person i've
heard mention that odd period where
there were no
uh ads on television for example right
it's a very important fact from the
perspective of how it felt to be right
but um it somehow hasn't been recorded
as an important part of the event the
way you know the falling man or the you
know the crash in pennsylvania or any of
these other things were right but in
some ways
it
is an important story about how this got
integrated into our into our fabric and
obviously the world is not the same
world that we lived in prior to 9 11 in
many ways i mean some of them structural
some of them uh cognitive but
it changed the world and
um
it's a pity that we at least in our
our common narrative of what happened
haven't captured that aspect of it
i also wanted to read something
that i wrote actually in the aftermath
of the terrorist attack in france in
2015 right so this is actually a couple
years before you and i emerged into the
public eye
i wrote something in the immediate
aftermath of that attack and submitted
it to salon
which at the time was still a
publication one could read
and
anyway to my surprise they immediately
accepted it and published it and anyway
when common dreams picked it up is that
right and then common dreams rebroadcast
it and
um anyway i thought
part of it was important and so anyway
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a read and
we'll put the link uh it's still up on
the web and we i'll put the link
in the description yeah you wanna show
the article
um yeah so as always the title is not
chosen by the author of the article but
it's let's not get this wrong this time
the terrorists won after 9 11 because we
chose to invade iraq and shred our
constitution
all right
i'm going to start a paragraph
in
terrorism is a tactic in which the
primary objective is to produce fear
rather than direct harm terrorist
attacks are first and foremost most
psychological operations designed to
alter behavior amongst the terrorized in
a way that the actors believe will serve
them
the 911 perpetrators killed about 3 000
people and did about 13 billion dollars
in physical damage to the united states
that's a lot of harm in absolute terms
but not relative to a nation of 300
million people with a gdp of almost 15
trillion dollars it was a massive blow
to many families and to new york city
but to the nation as a whole that level
of damage was about as dangerous as a
bee sting
you may find that analogy suspect
because bee stings are deadly to those
with an allergy but what kills people is
not the sting itself it is their own
massive overreaction to an otherwise
tiny threat that fatally disrupts the
functioning systems of the body and that
is exactly what terrorists hope to
trigger a muscular and reflexive
response on the part of the victim state
that advances the perpetrators interests
far beyond their own capacity to advance
them
the 911 attack was symbolic
it was not designed to [ __ ] us
economically or militarily at least not
directly it was designed to provoke a
reaction the reaction cost more than 6
000 american lives in wars in iraq and
afghanistan and more than 3 trillion
in u.s treasure
the reaction also caused the united
states to [ __ ] its own constitution
and radicalize the muslim world in a
reign of terror that has killed hundreds
of thousands of iraqi and afghani
civilians
the return on the terrorist investment
was spectacular assuming the official
story is right then al qaeda got seven
million dollars of effect for every
dollar it spent on the attack
seven million dollars to one
the ratio of harm inflicted on the u.s
targets uh by the 9 11 attacks to the
financial harm the u.s inflicted on
itself reflects the same amplification
for every one dollar of damage they did
to us we did 231 dollars to ourselves
for every american that was killed in
the attack we sacrificed more than two
on the battlefield and that is all
before we consider the instability we
brought to the middle east the harm we
did to our own freedoms and the
spectacular cost of our to our
reputation abroad
in any case it's extraordinary and uh so
prescient in uh unrelated realms today
right and this actually is one of the
reasons i wanted to read that is because
the idea that there are two things in
play there's the threat that you face
which is obviously real and then there's
the question of whether your reaction
successfully diminishes the harm does it
amplify the harm and this is something
that we always have to keep
in mind and as you point out at this
moment
we're not dealing with terrorism we're
dealing with other things but the same
question looms in a slightly different
way which is what is the best reaction
to this and what are the chances that in
an effort to uh
to fix our system we will actually do
more harm to it and possibly harm we
can't undo exactly and and we are you
know we're seeing
other countries around the world begin
to say
i believe i believe germany i believe
denmark i believe ira ireland begin to
say you know what
terrible disease awful virus
we're going back to life
we're going back to normal life uh
because we feel that we've done what we
can do
we will um hopefully continue to treat
uh and uh you know i think um because of
uh laws in europe things like planes are
still um you'll still have people with
masks on them and such
but for the most part life is going back
to normal even in countries uh that
continue to have covet and you know this
is a place um
you know you and i think slightly
disagree at this point back you know
when we when we published the substance
piece that we did at the end of july um
laying out what we understand to be um
our you know what we understand to be
science's current understanding with
regard to
things like um um off-label use of you
know repurposed drugs for treatment and
prophylaxis of of covid and the vaccines
and how um how universally um effective
a response that can be um we said and i
think even the title of the piece was uh
you know we we have to we have to get
rid of this virus we have to arrive at
extinction you have to drive it extinct
and um
i'm no longer convinced this is possible
um i am i am convinced and um
i i think i will remain convinced that
it was possible that it was possible and
it was possible for a very long time and
that we didn't do it and it's not
because uh some part of the population
refused to comply it's because um our
policies were bad
but uh given that it looks like it is an
ever more impossible target to actually
eradicate this thing and that we do live
uh with um you know far worse pathogens
things like things like rabies
he's like yellow fever and it's not that
those that
i'm not saying i like those things right
or that i think that we should encourage
them but that we live with them
uh
with plans in place to prophylaxis if we
can and to treat and to vaccinate if
it's possible and um you know the
countries that are saying enough is
enough
uh are
well you know let's see how how it works
for them but uh so far so good
yeah i think in some sense the
question about whether it is possible to
drive it extinct has become
politicized and like it's not even
possible to know the answer because the
data stream is so dirty right and you
know
i'm not saying i'm convinced it's
possible i i am convinced it was
possible i have seen nothing that tells
me it isn't possible in general the
arguments that people marshal that
suggest it isn't possible are not good
arguments and i think the real important
point is it actually doesn't matter
because
if it is not possible then the obvious
objective is to control it as well as
for example we control rabies right
babies is still with us we have no
mechanism for getting rid of it however
how many people die of rabies every year
you know within the us for example yes
and and you know of course there's a
massive difference uh in that
uh you know rabies has a case fatality
rate close to one
it is one i i i think there may have
been one case there's a thing one case
or someone says
somebody survived well surviving rabies
without getting treatment very quickly
surviving rabies with onset of symptoms
you can treat rabies having been uh
infected yeah so it's not gonna be the
cfr but yes yeah at the point that you
show symptoms um it's basically a death
sentence unless uh unless you've gotten
treatment um so it's it's a totally
different disease and yet we have
figured out how to live with it and have
decreased mortality to close to zero now
we're going to take a lot of crap for
analogizing the two because obviously
they're very different diseases
transmitted in a very different way but
nonetheless the point is complete
control of the disease has to be the
objective if extinction is out of range
and i don't think anyone actually knows
that extinction is out of range and you
know it's a discussion that we should be
having unfortunately because this is a
politicized question depending upon
whether uh
various parties are interested in
pretending that they have a plan to
drive it extinct or thwarting those who
would point out that their plan is no
good you'll hear both answers so
in any case
it is what it is but maybe uh unless
there's more to say
on this topic we should move on to what
the future might hold if we in fact uh
figure out how to
bring ourselves into it in a useful
fashion let's do it um
yeah so again this is a 13 chapter book
and there is an epilogue and an
afterwards so we may we may come back at
you next week again uh with with more
but um the 13th chapter is called the
fourth frontier and indeed um on on
rogan this week we talked about this
some so you in fact summarized
the frontiers that we were talking about
having existed before and what the
fourth frontier might be but i'm just
going to read
the section i'm starting a couple pages
into the chapter
um
again the final chapter of our book
hunter-gatherers guide to the 21st
century
humans thrive in almost every
terrestrial habitat on earth we are a
broadly generalist species with highly
specialized individuals who have
shape-shifted and niche shifted into
nearly every environment on the planet
this has meant interacting with
frontiers over and over and over again
here we describe three types of
historical frontiers geographic
technological and transfer of resource
then we will propose a fourth
geographic frontier is what we tend to
think of when frontiers are invoked the
vast unspoiled vistas the abundant and
yet uncounted resources
all of the new world north and south
america the caribbean and every island
near the coasts was a vast geographic
frontier for the baringians the frontier
of the new world was fractal so the
descendants of the first americans
discovered even more to the ahwanichi
indians yosemite valley
yosemite valley was a geographic
frontier to the tano the caribbean was a
geographic frontier to the suknam people
of far southern chile
tierra del fuego was a geographic
frontier
technological frontiers are moments when
innovation allows a human population to
make more or do more or grow more than
they did before the innovation occurred
every human culture that is terraced
hillsides decreasing runoff and
increasing crop production was
confronting technological frontiers from
the inca and the andes to the malagasy
on the oat plateau of madagascar
the first farmers in china mesopotamia
and mesoamerica were doing so and the
first ceramicists who dug clay formed
into useful shapes and fired in coals
were doing so as well
finally there are transfer of resource
frontiers
unlike geographic and technological
frontiers transfer of resource frontiers
are inherently a form of theft
when people from the old world came
across the atlantic and landed in the
new they may have at first imagined that
they had stumbled upon a fast geographic
frontier but they hadn't
in 1491 the new world is estimated to
have had between 50 and 100 million
people in it with uncountable distinct
cultures and languages
some people were living in city-states
among astronomers craftsmen and scribes
others as hunter-gatherers
to francisco pisarro the inca empire was
a transfer of resource frontier
to the instigators of the rubber boom in
western amazonia at the end of the 19th
century the sapporo territory was a
transfer of resource frontier and once
the sapporos were thus weakened their
longtime competitors the irani moved in
as well
in modern times transfer resource
frontiers are everywhere oil drilling
fracking and logging in ancestral lands
predatory lendings with subprime
mortgages and much student debt the
holocaust
one symptom of transfer resource
frontiers is tyranny
geographic frontiers represent the
discovery of resources heretofore
unknown to humans
geographic frontiers are inherently zero
sum there is a finite amount of space on
this planet of ours and we will reach
the end of it
technological frontiers are the creation
of resource through human ingenuity
technological frontiers are temporarily
non-zero sum specifically positive some
and this can appear to be a permanent
state
but there are physical limits a single
electron is the theoretical minimum
needed to flip from one state to another
in a transistor for instance
transfer of resource frontiers are theft
of resource from other human populations
like all frontiers transfer resource
frontiers are ultimately zero sum
theft has its limits even thieves must
obey physical laws
what choice do we have but to continue
seeking new frontiers and more growth
if our addiction is just a special human
case of a pattern that characterizes all
species that have ever lived are we not
simply condemned to write this
destructive trajectory to the end
we have written this book in part
because we believe the answer to that
question is no
humans are obsessed with growth because
it engenders bigger populations that if
nothing else have farther to fall before
going extinct but large populations also
pose a hazard to themselves so the
resources that enlarge them are finite
or fragile in such cases moderation is
the key but it only works of our drive
for growth our individual perception of
it is sustainably satisfied
we have run out of geographic frontiers
or nearly so
technological frontiers by turns
dazzling and disappointing come with
risks beware chesterton's fence and are
ultimately constrained by available
resources
transfer resource frontiers are immoral
and destabilizing what then are we to do
where to turn to find salvation in
simple terms consciousness
consciousness can point the way to a
fourth frontier
once again the human niche is niche
switching and consciousness is the
answer to novelty living sustainably on
a finite planet is a hard sell but we
can and we must find a way we have no
choice
these problems of novelty require
humanity's urgent attention and cannot
be solved by the good will or hard work
of individuals
we moderns have become a threat to our
own persistence we are built to figure
out how to move between modes of being
it is time to rise to collective
consciousness and prototype a way out of
this
we face some significant obstacles
humans like other creatures are obsessed
with growth
and we are capable of driving ourselves
extinct extinct in the pursuit of it
even though it is logically obvious that
we must accept equilibrium we are not
built to be satisfied with it because
being unsatisfied has been an excellent
strategy for the last several billion
years
there is a character trait of
individuals that may be critical to
finding the fourth frontier or rather
its adaptive foothill that could lead to
a society-wide solution
that is pride and craftsmanship
an artisan who takes pride in the
quality and durability of their work is
enacting some portion of a fourth
frontier mentality one in which the
lifespan of a product is as important as
its function
a table or sideboard made by a local
craftsperson is not beloved merely
because it is more beautiful than what
can be assembled from a box bought at
ikea but also because the person in
possession of a lovely and functional
piece has a chance of handing it down to
their children or other kin or friends
so too would we like to be able to
deliver onto the next generations a
lovely and functional world
the fourth frontier is a framework
therefore that can be understood with an
evolutionary toolkit it is not a policy
proposal the fourth frontier is the idea
that we can engineer an indefinite
steady state that will feel to people
like they live in a period of perpetual
growth but will abide by the laws of
physics and game theory that govern our
universe
think of it like the climate control
that allows the inside of your house to
hover at a pleasant spring temperature
as the world outside moves between
unpleasant extremes
engineering an indefinite steady state
for humanity will not be easy
but it is imperative
i have one more to share
about the maya before we end today but
um
we've ended up
we've done a fair bit of of media so far
most of which is not out there about the
book and
um
i thought we'd end up talking a lot
about the sex and gender chapter and
there have been a few
podcasts that we've done and we'll be
talking about all these um that have
specifically focused on that but it's
been interesting how many of them have
ended up being about about this about
the society
level um decoherence uh and how it is
that we can find our way out
well i think it's a mirror actually for
one of the
errors that we point to about
evolutionary theory as we find it today
and uh
i guess i need a little uh a little
leeway here but the idea is
that one has the sense based on what
evolutionists typically say that
evolutionary success is synonymous with
reproduction that producing more
offspring is better and of course
we can back that off slightly but in
general that is the the conventional
wisdom and it's the conventional wisdom
for a pretty good reason which is that
the real thing that selection is trying
to accomplish it's not really trying to
do anything but if it were it would be
trying to lodge genes
as deeply into the future as possible
and one way so zero is what we call an
absorbing boundary if your population
goes to zero it doesn't rebound from it
so
one way to not hit zero and therefore
fail to get into the entirety of the
future is to have a lot of individuals
right so reproduction is very closely
tied to many of the things that make you
evolutionarily successful but in and of
itself it's pointless
so
the point here is
there are a lot of problems that we face
right that are in some way downstream of
of our perceptions that selection has
awarded us in order that we can navigate
but the purpose of it is all the same
the purpose is to get into the future
and so the reason that many of the
things that we have talked about really
ultimately point to this question is no
matter what problem you solve it doesn't
much matter if you don't solve this one
right we have an obviously unsustainable
trajectory the hazard we now pose to
ourself is so immense that if we don't
solve it there is nothing to do right
you could turn hedonistic and you could
say all right let's just have a party
because there's nothing to be done about
this
and you know there's a reasonable
argument to be made but i think again as
with the question of can you drive this
uh
pathogen to extinction
we don't know there is nothing that has
been provided yet that tells us we can't
get out of this and in fact
we the point the one of the major themes
of the book is that what we do what our
species does what it is built for more
than anything else is getting out of
jams and figuring out what to do in the
new situation that nobody knows anything
about that's that's our niche we're so
good at it even when the jam is one that
we are abso ourselves have created
but uh we have now created a series of
jams to use your word uh that we have
not only created but are modifying at
such a rapid rate that it's really hard
to see our way out and we've done some
things that make it less likely so
um
the
the problem that we have is we have now
taken what we have as tools and we've
put them in a system that has its own
evolutionary dynamics our political and
economic system causes for example those
who have done something that has created
uh let's say a technological frontier
and have therefore become very wealthy
have the power to prevent change
and so
we talk about this need to rise to
collective consciousness in order to
begin problem solving to figure out how
to get out of the pickle we find
ourselves in but the problem is we now
have an opposing force which is
for anybody who succeeded brilliantly
change is frightening right because
unless that change is under some kind of
control
if you're a winner change can turn you
into a loser so there is this natural
tendency to frustrate change and the
problem is it won't make it's of no
value to anyone to preserve things in
this state if this state is
self-terminating but there's a game
theory problem where those who oppose
change actually retain and concentrate
their uh their fraction of our
collective
or their disproportionate fraction of
our our collective well-being and
you know cynically speaking even if the
world must be saved from these processes
somebody who opts not to participate in
that saving
uh phenomenon
right they actually end up better off
right so the uh the game theory the the
free rider problem applies even within
the category of elites who might group
together and decide to point us in the
right direction
so anyway though our our final chapter
is really about you know what what does
this puzzle really look like if we free
ourselves from the narratives that we
are handed that in large measure
frustrate our ability to see where we
are and where we might go and part of
what you were just alluding to is that
the stable state will not be static that
it is easy for people to conflate stable
with static
and
there will there can be no stable state
for humanity in which humans are
actually feeling
a sense of purpose and and and progress
and happiness and uh productivity uh
which is static and which can
also true that it therefore cannot be
defined uh in advance and um that that
definition will remain the same right
and in fact you know it it will be
subtle to many readers but what we say
about
the fact that this state cannot be
blueprinted we literally do not know
enough to say what the state will look
like what it must be is navigated
towards right that we will learn we will
bootstrap we will prototype our way
to this new state which also implies
some other things and this you know this
may be unsettling to people but this is
a multi-generational
process of navigation right the amount
of change necessary to reach a steady
state that truly does fulfill the human
desire for growth without needing to
find new sources of growth right that
process
let's say it takes three generations
right that means
we're not likely those who are old
enough to be paying attention to this
podcast we're not likely to
to be in that world right on the other
hand the process of going there we have
been falsely told
would be
a matter of austerity right oh you want
the world to function better and be
safer you're going to have to give up a
lot of stuff and i think this is
complete nonsense that actually we lack
meaning and useful things to do and that
a world in which we actually set about
trying to figure out how the future
should be would be a world in which
there was plenty to do and lots of
meaning and you know the fact that you
don't live to see the final state
doesn't make any difference because it
actually would be a better world almost
immediately upon our setting about this
journey
yeah and asking people in the west
asking people in the weird world uh to
embrace a policy of austerity from from
here on out
um would seem like an obvious ask given
our the relative wealth that we enjoy
and the resources that we have
um but it is also true and we write
about this in the book and i've written
about it elsewhere that um the the
meaning that we find in life is mostly
not in our stuff and our our relative
wealth and that it is therefore not in
the weird world where you tend to find
the people who have the most sense of
purpose and meaning and um
you know devotion to
to people and love and ideals that do
provide meaning so
um
giving up
stuff feels really hard for people right
now not because we're a bunch of selfish
greedy
jerks
but because most of us are actually
recognizing in our heart that no matter
how much luxury and comfort we may be
surrounded with there's actually
something real missing so
we can do this with you and i argue but
um
without giving up
a lot of the trappings
but also argue that it's not the
trappings where we're actually going to
find the meaning and what we need to do
is
create a way for people to
refine the connection and the meaning
and of course you know the last
i have to update my calendar but you
know the last 18 months 19 months now
has taken away so many of the
opportunities that people did have you
know some of what we were talking about
last time the
the
experiments and the opportunities for
collective joy the the parties and the
festivals and the carnivals and the
sporting events and the intimate
gatherings and the chance meetings on
the sidewalk that turn into a long walk
that turns into an evening that turns
into a relationship right like these
things are much harder to accomplish in
an era
of
restrictions and lockdowns and requests
for compliance with rules that have just
been handed to us without an explanation
for their justification honestly um and
so what we have had our meaning taken
from us um and that's hardly new but it
did accelerate over these last 18 19
months
um and before that as we talk about in
the book
some of the accelerators are you know
the usual suspects the the screens and
the junk everything the junk food the
junk sex the junk entertainment
uh the
the ability of advertisers to hook into
our short-term endocrinological systems
and give us our dopamine hit or
serotonin hit rather than
us being able to resist the dopamine hit
and the serotonin hit and look towards
um the the joy and deeper pleasures to
be found in the non-junk versions of
food and sex and entertainment and
meaning making and adventure and
creation and discovery and all of these
things
um i wanted to
maybe refine one aspect of that because
i do believe that part of our problem uh
with sustainability has to do with the
amount of material and energy necessary
to make the world work and we are we are
going to have to cut back but
the point i want to make is that is not
going to feel like austerity if done
well right so i want to
raise this issue um buckminster fuller
had a very ironic way of making this
point he had this
term
that he coined ephemeralization and his
definition for it was the process by
which you can do more and more with less
and less until eventually you can do
everything with nothing
which you know it's it's a beautiful
fullerism but
in any case the point is think about
something like it almost sounds like
homeopathy though
well the point is the very last bit is
an ironic twist because it is not
absolutely nothing that you can do it
with but the point is it can be
minimized you know a nanomaterial can
have great strength with almost no atoms
in it by virtue of geometry right of the
structures and so anyway i would just
point out this is an evil dangerous
device we all know that right but at a
technological and material level it is a
marvel right how many objects what does
this weigh it weighs you know three
quarters of a pound or something right
and
it's uh
a rather marvelous camera it's a
video camera it's a telephone it's uh
it's a map
it's a library like none that has ever
existed on earth
right it's a lot of things that actually
don't even have a name separate from it
right or separate from the revolution
that it accompanied right and so the
point is it's not all the way to a
femoralization it's not a heads-up
display that emerges out of no material
that you're carrying around thank god
well right but my point is the number of
atoms in this thing is many but it's not
many relative to the number of objects
it replaces and so it's a lot fewer
atoms than an eniac which did a hell of
a lot less yeah did effectively nothing
um right i mean it calculated things
like trajectories for bombs and stuff
that you know it's a trivial calculation
by modern standards but
that's the question is how do you
deliver the animal which is what we are
how do you deliver it the somatic
sensation of this is a good safe
functional world in which i am liberated
to do the things that actually make a
difference to me and allow me to make
the world better which is really what
the the objective you know we have this
cruddy system where if it makes a profit
then we sort of imagine that you
probably created wealth maybe there's
value in that
but there's so much market failure where
your profit was made and it really
wasn't that you made the world better
you just externalized harm onto somebody
else its externality is all the way down
all the way down right so many negative
externalities so the question is well
you know
you may not be able to instantiate it
but ideally what you'd like is an
economic system in which you got paid
when you made the world better when you
actually did create wealth and you
didn't get paid for creating negative
externalities or any other exploiting
market failure of any kind and so
um
the real i mean we have two levels of
question
and in fact i once
uh
i won't go into it but i do think it's
important to separate out the question
of what structure would make the world
function from the question of is there
any way to get there because the answer
to is there any way to get there could
be no it could be that the obstacles
that those who oppose this because they
find it threatening are too strong and
you can't get there but it doesn't
change the uh importance of the question
about what what would a functional
system look like
and so anyway we are we are
we need to recast this in the public
mind so that people understand that they
are not being told that they need to
live like monks in order for us to get
into the future because that's not it
they need to
um
retool their expectations a bit and
you know
what we say in the book about the fact
that it's always spring in your house
and that that's really what we're
talking about we're not talking about uh
either anything that violates any known
law the spring in your house doesn't
violate any known law because when it's
uh hot out um we cool your house with an
air conditioner that slightly heats your
backyard right it all makes sense you
just keep the coolness on one side of
the wall
and and as we talked about on on rogan
uh when you change your diet to
something that is better for you your
your physiology and the gut microbiome
that you have on board actually changes
so that you come to appreciate the thing
better and what he raised um which
hadn't occurred to me but the but the
way of marking progress in martial arts
being a change of color in the in the
belt that you have
adds value without coming with much of a
cost and that's you know that those are
the sorts of solutions and and the same
thing with pride and craftsmanship that
we also that we also talk about in that
section that i read from
that
finding
finding value not just in the minimalist
reductionist
version of what the thing is well all i
need is a chair and therefore i need
something that holds me up when i try to
sit okay
are there other things that a chair
could offer you that would provide more
value and the construction of which
would therefore also provide more value
for the person constructing it of course
there are we've all sat in garbage
chairs and and better chairs regardless
of how you know of your surroundings
you've sat in variable quality chairs
and the quality isn't just about the
comfort it's also about the level of
construction and you can intuit
something about what the thought was
that went into it yeah whether it's
garbage chairs or garbage trucks i mean
you know the fact
some of us have not sat in garbage
trucks uh except by that use of the term
garbage i guess right yeah
one way or the other i had a it wasn't a
garbage truck but i had a not too
awesome truck there for a while yeah
yeah back in grad school it was okay it
was all right it was yeah but uh
yeah it went from here and often got to
there it usually it usually does yeah
f-150 for those of you who wonder um
anyway
an old one though
people used to say friends don't let
friends drive forwards
i do and so we actually
i have no idea whether that still
applies right yeah before well we
started hearing that after we were
literally in a ford bronco that caught
fire in the middle of nebraska in a
snowstorm and we had to abandon it there
um which is a story for another time but
then much later i ended up with this uh
ford f-150 that was old and you know
rusty and michigan and all this but it
it got me from here to there yeah and i
often got my bike there too so it was it
was fine
okay um let's talk a little bit about
the maya um the maya
beringians the original americans um are
a recurring theme throughout the book
and in fact we opened with it the very
first chapter the beringians and the the
original people in the americas
um and the maya
loom very large in our thinking and um
and are not as as frequent um players in
the book as originally this is you know
this we cover a lot of ground here and
this isn't that thick a book
but here's a little section on the maya
from this final chapter
in many regards the problems we are
facing now are ones we have faced before
every culture in human history has
engaged in both cooperation and
competition and behaved both in ways
that ought to make us proud to be human
and in those that make us ashamed
both glorious and ghastly actions have
been widespread
when looking back on history we have the
responsibility to recognize that truth
and also to recognize when our ancestors
wins legitimate or very often not have
provided us advantage that we did not
ourselves earn
it is not however our responsibility to
subjugate ourselves to those histories
europeans indeed stole land from native
americans and often grew some despicable
ways
the native americans who were thus
subjugated themselves had a history of
warfare and conquest in the new world
taking land from one another
and of course none of this was new they
brought it with them to the new world
when they crossed over from burundia
many thousands of years earlier
let us not romanticize any people or
period let us instead understand
humanity holistically and work to
provide opportunity equally to everyone
going forward
in this book we have shared an
evolutionary toolkit with which to
understand the human condition not to
justify it
we are not served by ignoring what we
are
brutal apes by one measure we are not
served by oh we are also not served by
pretending that brutal apes are the only
thing that we are we are also generous
cooperative beings full of love
we have arrived in the 21st century with
evolutionary baggage and a fair bit of
intellectual confusion
let us understand the baggage in order
to reduce the confusion and increase our
odds of moving forward with maximal
human flourishing
as an aid to this end let us consider
the maya
the maya thrived for over two and a half
millennia and mesoamerica surviving
droughts and enemies and other
unpleasant extremes
in the now ancient city-states of the
maya including not just tikal but also
ekbalam chachuben and so many more stone
pyramids and temples are still visible
above the tops of the trees
on the forest floor footpaths run
between ancient buildings as do a
goodies lizards in the occasional ocelot
more substantial roads sakbays connect
city-states
most of the mayan city-states emerged as
political economic and cultural forces
to be reckoned with long before the
roman empire existed
wholly unaware of the other's existence
the maya and the romans were at their
peak at the same time in the early part
of the first millennium and both were an
obvious decline by the beginning of the
second
the maya had an enlightenment of their
own long before the european
enlightenment we will never know its
extent
we will never know its extent
as the vast majority of their books were
destroyed by europeans
the mayan civilization was spread widely
across the yucatan peninsula extending
south through modern belize and
guatemala and just barely dipping into
honduras
the maya were dominant in these
landscapes for 2 500 years but they were
not monolithic and their successes waxed
and waned over both time and space
city-states collapsed droughts caused
the abandonment of once fertile lands
and while some areas were repopulated by
the maya others never were the maya were
intensive agriculturalists who farmed on
poor tropical soils but managed to
maintain soil fertility for a remarkably
long time through successful land
management
they dealt with the hilly slopes that
were ubiquitous throughout much of their
range with at least six types of
terracing systems they used complex
reservoirs to conserve water during
annual dry seasons and during less
predictable longer dry spells
it is also true however
that where they cleared cleared forests
the land was generally degraded and soil
quality fell
by the time the spaniards arrived the
maya were already in decline they had
had a long run and what exactly
precipitated their collapses up for
debate
while the mayan culture largely
disappeared the mayan people persist
they were not a fragile people or
culture they were robust and
long-standing
long-lasting
one indication of just how long a run
they had is that they had a unit of time
the bactoon equal to 144 000 days almost
400 years
they were so long lived as a people and
so accustomed to thinking across long
time spans that they use the bactoon to
help keep track of time
the durability of the maya suggests that
the potential exists
that the potential exists for conscious
directed enlightenment in which we take
ownership of our own evolutionary state
like the maya we moderns need to find
ways to flatten the boom bust cycle that
has plagued all populations across time
we hypothesize that the maya did this by
creating a mechanism for not turning
excess resources into more people or
ephemeral things
instead they invested in giant public
works projects
many of these public works projects are
visible today as temples as pyramids
they grew them like onions building more
layers in times of abundance in years of
plenty we posit when excess food could
easily have been turned into more people
which would have expanded the population
making hunger and conflict inevitable in
lean years the maya instead turned the
extra food into pyramids or into bigger
pyramids
they created glorious and useful public
spaces enjoyable by all and when
agricultural boom years inevitably ceded
to bust years the temples required no
nourishment and the population could
withstand the leaner times
western civilization has been dominant
for nearly as long as the maya were
their culture unraveled accelerated at
the end by a hostile enemy from across
an ocean
our culture is unraveling as well
we need a new steady state an
evolutionarily stable strategy we need
to find the fourth frontier
and then we talk about obstacles and i
should say before i know you have things
to respond to in that um
the obstacles that we talk about to the
fourth frontier come from both the left
and the right and this is you know this
is an explicitly apolitical book in
which we identify ourselves as
politically liberal but liberals who can
identify the types of errors that
liberals the people on the left side of
the spectrum are more likely to make and
also identify the types of errors that
people on the right side of the spectrum
are more likely to make and um and point
out as has been pointed out by many at
other times but many modern seem to have
forgotten that we need the tension that
we need people on both sides of a divide
as long as we share basic fundamental
values and a belief in each other's
humanity
the disagreeing about exactly where we
are and how to get to a better future
makes for
the possibility of progress whereas
tamping down all dissent does not
yes and in fact i i think it makes sense
i still don't know how to make the point
so people hear it but
um
we are liberals but that is a
a measure of where we believe we are in
history it's not a fundamental
characteristic or a belief that um
progress is inherently good right it's a
question of where we are and a
recognition that we cannot possibly stay
here just in an even simple
extrapolation
of how much resource we are using and
how many of us there are and what that
implies about the near term tells us
this is not a an evolutionarily stable
strategy that we are currently engaged
in and therefore we have no choice but
to change but
the the point is and as you point out
this is something
enlightened conservatives agree on
which is that it is the tension between
the impulse to solve problems and a
healthy fear of the unintended
consequences of solution-making that
results in a society that functions and
does not
constantly upend itself
with
naive errors
so um you know are we at the place where
we should all be progressives because
progress is absolutely required i think
so and maybe that's something you know
it will be interesting to see whether
that message from the book lands whether
people see
see that
necessity but the
those who would misunderstand you
intentionally
might hear
that any progress that is happening is
therefore good which of course is absurd
and um and you know we could we could
i think accurately argue that so much of
the change that is happening now
certainly does not look like what
happened before and therefore could be
semantically called progress but is not
actually uh progressing us to anything
like a better future yeah it's like
progressing through time isn't the same
thing as progress in the way we mean it
and unfortunately i think
narrative plays two roles that we
haven't really separated yet you and i
both agree that the way you move
people forward the way history moves
forward in the positive sense has to do
with compelling narratives not
compelling analyses nobody pays
attention
uh except for you know a small number of
people to
orwell's uh political philosophy right
we pay attention to 1984 because it
makes the point of that political
philosophy in a way that's very visceral
so narrative and it's easier to confuse
people with analysis and numbers and
graphs precisely because
it's not native for for many people and
you know i think um
many especially you know like
intellectual elites media elites and
such um
actually seem to agree with the
widespread sentiment that just most
people are dumb most people can't take
it most people aren't interested and so
you just need to hand them pre-digested
pap
we don't we never have and that was
evident in our classrooms but what i do
do believe and did see
is that most people
do not really think uh quantitatively
very well they don't think with numbers
very well and i believe that having that
as a as a weakness
um
is
is runs hand-in-hand with therefore
being more easily uh confused and lied
to with those sorts of tools right
people i think they you know if you're
talking to an honest broker who knows
what they're talking about and they
present an analysis where you can't
quite follow the math but you can you
understand what the conclusion of it is
you're not in no danger but you're in
less danger but the problem is when you
have no idea who it is who's constructed
the analysis i mean this is this was the
point of how to lie with statistics
which is right for people who aren't in
a position to check the underlying logic
statistics are a place that you can bury
a lot of bodies
um so anyway narrative on the one hand
is the way you would move things forward
positively but we also live in a
landscape where
everything is basically subject to
official narratives that
do not appear to have our interests at
heart and so you know surrendering to
the idea that narrative is perhaps the
most important thing but that it is also
a landscape that is uh ripe for abuse
is
maybe part of the
the tension of of our of our moment
um
did you have more to say there well i
did it did occur to me as you were
reading that section of the book that
maybe one way um
to move at least one of our intentions
forward is to write
uh
a sequel
called something like um
the caterpillar who was unknowingly at
fault for his own hunger that that book
might actually bridge the divide between
these two narratives and we might be
able to move forward from there um pick
up some of the uh uh
what's it even forgot what the
caterpillar book is called
a very hungry caterpillar like
picking up some of that audience well i
just don't think that this caterpillar
is entitled to be freed
from all responsibility for his
predicament you think his insatiability
is his own doing in one way or another i
feel certain of that yes
i do not remember the plot of the book
so i can't really know that that's i
mean the plot is just that he eats
everything but i don't remember the
conclusion
all right yeah i have the feeling it was
it's kind of thin on plot which is um
you know
true for a certain style of children's
books
it's then on plot okay i'm pretty sure
it's going to end with him turning i
mean i'd prefer it if it was a moth
right
um why because it's more surprising but
i have the sense that that the
caterpillar probably turns into a
beautiful diurnal butterfly and uh lives
happily ever after for the next two
weeks
or something like that yes it's true i'm
actually i don't know
um this is definitely the moment to get
into what we do and do not know about
lepidopteran biology right you and me or
science no no no
yes so i don't know if um
if actually it's if any adult uh
butterflies or moths lepidoctrins um
live
a long time
or even if um if they will tend to live
as long as they spent as as larva the
larval form is often longer yeah
it varies a lot because the larval form
has so much resource accumulation to
make i think certain things like
sphingid moths are actually fairly long
lived you know we know a guy we will ask
our expert friend and
absolutely actually we should we should
do a thing on sphingid moths
are really fingers are sphinx moths um
gorgeous yeah they're beautiful
sometimes mistaken for hummingbirds
because of their flight agility
um are you serious yeah
i didn't know that yeah mistaken for
hummingbirds sure i think i may even
have done it once or twice you know okay
something flies by
but uh anyway they're
nocturnal so it's not so easy to confuse
them but there are moments in the day
when it can happen yeah and there is
actually as i mentioned at the top of
the hour uh some a section in the book
in which we ask um if a butterfly
remembers being a caterpillar um and the
answer is presumably not and there
wouldn't be much value value there
presumably not because there would be so
little value exactly exactly
um
so i guess i wanted just to
finish
maybe finish um by reviewing just you
know repeating we've spent these last 13
weeks going you know doing a little bit
from each chapter and saying what they
are
and uh and then also mentioning just
this week i think i've got a i've got an
almost complete list of the various
media appearances that are going to be
um dropping this week that i think
people might be interested in you know
some of them will appeal to some and
some to others
and
i think you and i sort of agreed about a
couple of them seeming particularly um
insightful i think one thing that has
been interesting is how different
they've all been there haven't been two
that have been alike that's right yes
which is a good sign yeah um and so this
list that i'm gonna read is not all the
ones that we've done and include some we
haven't yet done um but it's just the
ones that i understand will be released
this week or already have been
um so you know joe rogan is out um
we were in dallas uh meeting glenn beck
and i believe
he is putting that out today
and um tomorrow uh our conversation with
derek jensen of deep green resistance is
going to be out
and then on
launch day mind and matter with nick
jacombes and i do want to come back to
those three because those three were
really remarkable conversations and you
know glenn beck is obviously on the
right
famously conservative and derek jensen
is a radical environmental leftist and
um and so and we've got you know we've
we've just got this sort of gamut um
of of political ideology represented
among people whom we are
interested in talking to you know our
politics are close to derek's um but we
find all of these people just
extraordinary to talk to um so also
um megyn kelly on launch date will be
live with her uh the unspeakable podcast
with megan dom will be out this week um
i believe you're going to be very
briefly on tucker carlson on launch date
um the michaela peterson podcast we got
this week the federalist
the skeptic with michael sherburne that
was also a very good conversation impact
theory with tom bilyeu also a really
good conversation we'll be live with
trigonometry
um and the deborah soh podcast very good
conversation and there's going to be a
lovely interview and excerpt published
in root quarterly in their forthcoming
issue so did you want to say anything
about uh glenn beck
derek jensen or uh nick jacombs with
mind and matter three very different um
well venues i think you know your
grouping is an interesting one and i
think it it we enjoyed all of them and
they've all been very different i
thought those three excellent
conversations
and
you know there was no
there was no sense with you know
glenn beck was very clear about what the
political
distinctions between us likely were and
how little it matters in light of the
kinds of questions
that uh we are faced with and you know
he
did give the sense of being a very
genuine
deep caring person feels bad for certain
features of
his history and is very interested in
making the world better as he sees that
possibility
um so anyway i think people are going to
enjoy that conversation
even though i
wildly flubbed his question about our
deep history chapter um so this is a
this i'll just say before you go on
talking about the other two um
the chapter that actually we wrote first
and that i just i loved i loved writing
the deep history chapter which basically
says okay here's where life started and
let's do a quick run through through the
human lineage back from 3.5 billion
years ago
and it was you know six thousand words
isn't much to write that history and
then um he basically said you wanna you
wanna summarize that and i was like oh i
promise not to take three and a half
billion years to summarize it but i sort
of got lost around animals and then you
picked it up and started talking about
something else so we never got back to
it we didn't even get to talk about the
origin of you know bones and heart and
brains but
anyway it it was a very difficult
question um which you know it's a little
bit like uh yeah could you summarize
what happened at evergreen in five
minutes and you know well fair enough
okay anyway um but
i'm not sure how much there is to say i
think people should listen to these
conversations well so um derek jensen um
it's an it's an hour-ish long
conversation and um
he
you know he like you know glenn beck
like i think they have very little in
common at one level except i think that
both of them could actually talk to each
other just as we can talk very easily to
both of them um
appreciated the book you know he's got a
background i think an undergraduate
degree in physics
and is an
active environmentalist um but but he
doesn't consider himself a scientist and
he he reported that he felt like we
really
went deep on important scientific
theories and principles and explained it
in a way that he could understand and
relay them so i really appreciate that
and then nick jacombes is himself a
scientist and we had like a three-hour
conversation with him in which he he
went almost point by point you know
obviously you can't do all the points in
the book but we did really a sort of a
thorough review of many of the salient
points in the book yeah it was great and
it yeah i think that that is a a good
point sort of a continuum between a
technical exploration of the book and a
generalist survey and you know one thing
that we were shooting for in writing the
book was a book that was accessible at
all these levels that actually does
contribute new ideas that are
significant and change the way we should
view ourselves and our evolutionary
nature
but that is accessible to people who
don't have any background and want to to
dive in and you know figure out what the
the toolkit that we
generated and taught to students really
allows you to see and you know it has
very practical advice about how you
should change your approach to various
things
so anyway
it's a little early to know whether
we've succeeded but those conversations
are
suggestive that maybe maybe we did
yeah and there and there will be more so
i intend to
say who you know where else you can see
conversations about the book as as it
continues and you know as it is
as it comes out this week um
maybe just these last three paragraphs
sure of
the final chapter
before the epilogue before the afterward
before the acknowledgments of glossary
etc etc
from the moment when our ancestors
achieved ecological dominance
competition
competition
between populations has been our
dominant selective force
millions of years of evolution have
refined our circuitry for such
competition and it has become the
default at the human software level
now though three things conspired to
make the inclinations that brought us to
this moment an existential threat to our
future
the scale of the human population
the unprecedented power of the tools at
our disposal and the interconnectedness
of the systems on which we depend
global economy ecology and reach of
technology
the importance of understanding human
software is urgent
the problem we face is the product of
evolutionary dynamics
all plausible solutions involve
awareness of those dynamics
the problem is evolutionary
so is the solution
all right
are we there i think we are there next
time we
return on our next live stream the book
will be actually
out in the world yeah so so please
consider um consider buying it and uh
definitely definitely consider reading
it
and uh we look forward to
continuing to talk about this for a long
time to come there may have been an
opportunity to have like in-person
events in which we discuss this at some
point although that's not going to
happen this fall for um sort of
obvious american
code reasons
so we're going to take for those of you
watching now if you want to stay tuned
we will take your questions as many of
them as we can get to in about 15
minutes on a separate stream on both
odyssey and youtube you can ask those
questions at darkcoresubmissions.com
mostly please consider
looking getting the book and reading it
this week but we also of course have
patreons we have stuff at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
we i have a
sub stack in which i'll actually be um
having an excerpt a very small excerpt
from the book this tuesday at
naturalselections.substance.com
you can email logistical questions to
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com including
we've been getting requests for hey you
know the audiobook doesn't seem to be
available in new zealand hey is it going
to be published in french this sort of
thing and um we are forwarding those
things to the relevant people so that
hopefully we get answers soon
and um please
consider subscribing to um the channels
both on odyssey and on youtube the main
channel brett weinstein and the clips
channel darkhorse podcast clips
anything you want to end with i don't
think so all right be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you